You may not be as speedy as him, but you'll
certainly want to race as fast as you can
to see Sonic the Hedgehog on the silver screen
next year.
Looper recently spoke with Sonic the Hedgehog
composer Tom Holkenborg, also known as Junkie
XL, who has scored films like Deadpool, Batman
v Superman: Dawn of Justice, Mad Max: Fury
Road, Alita: Battle Angel, and the newly released
Terminator: Dark Fate.
In conversation, we asked if there was anything
about Sonic that Holkenborg could tease — without
spilling spoilers, of course.
Holkenborg had some promising words to share:
"The only thing I can say is that it turned
out to be a really, really great film, and
it's so much fun to work on it.
Really great characters.
Really lovely, really cute at the same time.
So I'm looking forward for that to finish."
Anticipation for the project, based on Sega's
beloved video game franchise of the same name,
has been palpable from the minute Paramount
Pictures announced in October 2017 that it
would be fast tracking the film to development.
Hype continued to build in February 2018,
when Paramount confirmed Sonic the Hedgehog
would race into cinemas in November 2019.
Fans finally got their first look at the long-awaited
movie in a trailer that was released in April,
2019.
"Ahhhh!"
"AHHHHH!!!!"
When that footage finally arrived, however,
reception was mixed at best and shockingly
bad at worst.
The majority of fans felt that the most important
component of Sonic the Hedgehog, Sonic himself,
lacked a certain something in his design.
As a CGI character interacting with humans
like Jim Carrey's villainous super-scientist
Dr. Robotnik and James Marsden's friendly
Montana sheriff Tom Wachowski, Sonic needed
to look picture-perfect.
Many fans weren't completely satisfied with
the way Sonic appeared in the first trailer
for the film, and Paramount took the criticisms
in stride before making an important decision.
Shortly after the unveiling of the first Sonic
the Hedgehog trailer, director Jeff Fowler
announced that the special effects team would
be going back to the drawing board to give
Sonic a design overhaul.
He tweeted in May 2019:
"Thank you for the support.
And the criticism.
The message is loud and clear... you aren't
happy with the design & you want changes.
It's going to happen.
Everyone at Paramount & Sega are fully committed
to making this character the BEST he can be."
The filmmaker subsequently confirmed that
the redesign would delay the film, which is
now slated to open in theaters on February
14, 2020.
Since then, we've seen peeks of what could
be a possible Sonic redesign floating around
online, with one photo even showing the new
Sonic on an in-theater promotional standee.
The snaps suggest that the Sonic the Hedgehog
team has done a bang-up job improving the
character's appearance.
In fact, it looks like the design team were
quickly able to give fans basically everything
they could want from the reworked design.
The conversation surrounding the original
Sonic design was mixed, at best.
Some fans seemed to delight in collectively
roasting the character's original movie design,
poking fun at his creepy human teeth and odd
body proportions.
While some fans were somewhat more positive,
that still left Paramount with a pretty clear
indication that fans weren't going to be happy.
When the photos of the alleged redesign surfaced
on social media, many who were initially critical
of Sonic the Hedgehog changed their tune,
complimenting the new design and admitting
that they were keen to see the film.
One even wrote on Twitter that the purported
visual update Sonic received looks so incredible
that other teams handling Sonic-related content
and products could stand to learn a thing
or two from the Sonic the Hedgehog film team.
They wrote,
"[Movie Sonic's] redesign is so good it even
makes the modern sonic design from the games
look bland in comparison."
It's clear that everyone involved with Sonic
the Hedgehog is working fast to create a satisfying
final product.
And based on what Tom Holkenborg told us,
the film is going to be more than worth it
in the end.
Sonic the Hedgehog will hit theaters on February
14, 2020.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.